the excitement the commotion of the
first Saturday sitting for nearly four
decades seemed remote today all in
Westminster was quiet but behind closed
doors in the different quarters of power
the various players were ruminating on
what might happen next and what they
should do about it for the government as
far as they're concerned and despite the
p.m. being forced to ask for an
extension he promised he never would
it's full steam ahead we're going to
deliver by the 31st of October we are
going to ensure that we get this deal
done and I'm confident but with the
support of good people with whom we may
have disagreed in the past but who
respect democracy we will get this deal
done if you're betting man would you put
money on up yes I have you have okay how
much well that's between me and the
health secretary and indeed votes do
keep coming in for the deal virtually
all Tories and expelled Tories are now
on board including amber rod who had
wavered in terms of the economy it's
very good for northern and it's less
good for the rest of the Union so I
thought that Teresa Mays deal was the
right deal I think this is not as good
but I will I will nevertheless support
it
what
[Laughter]
the trouble is the government have lost
control of the process the speaker looks
likely to deny the government the chance
to consider the deal again as it's been
voted on already and so the only option
left for the government will be to
introduce new legislation to withdraw
agreement bill to pave the way for the
deal the problem is that can be amended
and changed in every direction possible
into something the government doesn't
like including even another referendum
which Labour says they'll push for what
we've said is Boris Johnson should take
this deal back to the people we've also
said you know we want a general election
- and in that general election we've
said we would negotiate a sensible
option for brexit and they would put
that before the people but it isn't a
referendum which would cause most
trouble now that's likely to come from
other amendments which might attract
more cross-party support in particular
keep your eye on the idea of a permanent
customs union amendment that could be
very popular in that place and not only
would it leave us with a much softer
brexit it would fundamentally transform
Boris Johnson's brexit deal right a
coach and horses through this newfound
conservative party unity and essentially
lead us right back to square one
perhaps Johnson's best hope now is for
the EU to reject his extension requests
but that seems unlikely yesterday the
Prime Minister came so close to victory
this week
victory will likely not only be elusive
but move further and further away Lewis
Caroll's Sky News Westminster